In this video, we'll discuss the
meaning of data visualization,
and why it's often useful to
visualize your data to discover
hidden trends and properties.
Data visualization is defined
as a mapping of data properties
to visual properties.
Data properties are usually
numerical or categorical,
like the mean of a variable,
the maximum value of a variable,
or the number of observations
with a certain property.
Visual properties can be (x,y)
coordinates to plot points
on a graph, colors to assign
labels, sizes, shapes, heights,
etc.
Both types of properties are
used to better understand
the data, but in different ways.
To motivate the need
for data visualization,
let's look at a famous example
called Anscombe's Quartet.
Each of these tables corresponds
to a different data set.
We have four data sets, each
with two variables, x and y.
Just looking at
the tables of data,
it's hard to notice
anything special about it.
It turns out that the mean
and variance of the x variable
is the same for
all four data sets,
the mean and variance
of the y variable
is the same for
all four data sets,
and the correlation
between x and y, as well as
the regression
equation to predict y
from x, is the exact same
for all four data sets.
So just by looking
at data properties,
we might conclude that these
data sets are very similar.
But if we plot the four data
sets, they're very different.
These plots show
the four data sets,
with the x variable
on the x-axis,
and the y variable
on the y-axis.
Visually, these data
sets look very different.
But without visualizing them,
we might not have noticed this.
This is one example of
why visualizing data can
be very important.
We'll use the
ggplot2 package in R
to create data visualizations.
This package was created
by Hadley Wickham, who
described ggplot as "a
plotting system for R
based on the grammar
of graphics, which
tries to take the good parts
of base and lattice graphics
and none of the bad parts.
It takes care of many of
the fiddly details that
make plotting a hassle
(like drawing legends)
as well as providing a powerful
model of graphics that makes it
easy to produce complex
multi-layered graphics."
So what do we gain
from using ggplot
over just making plots
using the basic R functions,
or what's referred to as base R?
Well, in base R, each
mapping of data properties
to visual properties is
its own special case.
When we create a scatter plot,
or a box plot, or a histogram,
we have to use a completely
different function.
Additionally, the graphics are
composed of simple elements,
like points or lines.
It's challenging to create any
sophisticated visualizations.
It's also difficult to add
elements to existing plots.
But in ggplot, the
mapping of data properties
to visual properties is done by
just adding layers to the plot.
This makes it much easier to
create sophisticated plots
and to add to existing plots.
So what is the
grammar of graphics
that ggplot is based on?
All ggplot graphics
consist of three elements.
The first is data,
in a data frame.
The second is an
aesthetic mapping,
which describes how
variables in the data frame
are mapped to
graphical attributes.
This is where we'll define
which variables are on the x-
and y-axes, whether or not
points should be colored
or shaped by certain
attributes, etc.
The third element is
which geometric objects
we want to determine
how the data values
are rendered graphically.
This is where we indicate if the
plot should have points, lines,
bars, boxes, etc.
In the next video, we'll
load the WHO data into R
and create some data
visualizations using ggplot.